it is a tremendous honor today as
u.s ambassador in guatemala to have the
opportunity to introduce to you
this distinguished group of guatemalan
community leaders
who come from a very diverse background
and a set of diverse
organizations but also work in a very
diverse range of ways
to support inclusion economic
opportunity
rule of law transparency and justice
all of which of course are fundamental
to a more prosperous
democratic and secure guatemala as well
as
addressing the root causes of irregular
migration
i know that all them are looking forward
to an excellent conversation with you
today
and so i want to begin by passing you
the virtual microphone for your initial
uh remarks and then after that i'll
introduce
our first two presenters thank you very
much
thank you muto gusto thank you mr
ambassador um and thank you all for
being here i'm
looking at a big screen and looking at
all of you
there i only what would it be better is
to be with you in person but i plan on
doing that soon but i'm looking at you
and very thankful for all of you taking
the time
to join us for this meeting and mr
ambassador thank you for bringing
everyone together
i have been looking forward to this
meeting for quite some time
i think the ambassador has shared that
president joe biden
has asked me to take the lead on our
nation's diplomatic efforts
with guatemala and throughout your
region
you know the word diplomacy generally
suggests
a relationship between government
leaders
but i believe it has to be broader than
that it has to
be more than that and that's why we are
building a comprehensive strategy
that includes business leaders
foundation leaders
and community leaders like you you
i believe are the vital voices
of this region and that is why the day
after i met with your president
which was yesterday i am meeting with
you today
i believe you know exactly what is
happening on the ground
exactly how much people are suffering
and exactly why people are leaving their
homes
and i know that there are acute factors
um the the acute factors that i think of
are the catastrophes that are
causing people to leave right now the
hurricanes the pandemic
the drought extreme food insecurity
and then i believe there are the
long-standing issues
what we call the root causes corruption
violence and poverty and of course the
lack of
economic opportunity and the lack of
not only climate mitigation but climate
adaptation and the lack of good
governance when we talk about these
acute factors
and the root causes we often hear
the statistics the policy people will
talk about statistics they'll talk about
the number
of people living in poverty they'll talk
about the number of people who are food
insecure
the number of people who have
experienced violence
but the reason i wanted to to be with
you and to hear from you
is you know the people behind these
numbers
that these are not just statistics you
know
their stories you know their struggles
and i believe that you can help me
identify
which communities are most in need of
support
and so when i think about it and i
mentioned this to the president
yesterday to your president
when i think about this i think about
some of the people who are most in need
of support are women
and youth afro descendants
lgbtq people and of course the
indigenous people
of guatemala and i believe we must
defend
the human rights of all people
so you can also help us understand
which geographic areas are most in need
of relief
my focus is such that i recognize it is
not just going to be a broad
sweeping approach that there are regions
that are more in need than others
and i'd like you to give me some
perspective on where those regions are
because we are going to take a what we
call a place based approach
so that the kind of information you give
us can be incorporated into our focus
on specific places that are most in need
finally i'd like you to tell me
what has been working and what has not
been working
you have been doing this work for so
long i have read about each one of you
i have read about your long-standing
commitment
and and so i want to learn from you what
has worked from your
perspective and what has not and what
might work
what has not been tried that could work
um and i'd love to get your thought on
on
policies and in particular which u.s
policies which policies from the united
states
have and have not worked in the past and
also
on what conditions community
organizations in guatemala need
in order to thrive your inside
experience both of those together are
invaluable
and so is your partnership so today i
want to hear from you
i want to hear about your work i want to
hear about what would give the people of
your country hope
what are their dreams what are their
dreams for their children
when they pray whether it is a silent or
a spoken
prayer what are the people praying for
and um so this is part of what i'd like
to learn from you today
it is also my intention to travel there
in june and to meet with you in person
but before you before you begin to share
with me your thoughts and perspective
let me say again thank you
i know how hard you work i know how hard
the work
is i know that the work we do together
is going to take time and that anything
we do together will not become visible
overnight but i know it will be
important work
and i know this is work that must happen
so the meeting we are having today is
one of several
that i intend to have um leading up to
some that i've had already here in the
united states
um to lead up to my visit to guatemala
in june and between now and then
and after i look forward to continuing
the conversation
and the work we can do together and
i do believe we are in this together
part of my approach to this
is recognizing that we are all neighbors
within the western hemisphere
and we have a responsibility then to
think about our role
in the context of our neighbors so again
thank you and
and i look forward to our conversation
thank you madam vice president it's now
my
honor to introduce you
you